[Musik]
lockdown befürworte ich mich weil ich
denke dass unsere wirtschaft oder
zumindest einige teile das nicht mehr
packen werden gerade kleinere läden ich
bin ein befürworter der impfpflicht weil
ich glaube dass das die einzige
möglichkeit ist sich weiter zu schützen
und alle zu schützen angst halte ich für
unangebracht angst schürt er gewisse
dinge die vielleicht auch für den
allgemeinen zustand nicht so ideal sind
respekt klar wir haben möglichkeiten uns
davor zu schützen soweit es im rahmen
halt gibt von daher denke ich mir wir
kommen damit schon ganz gut zurecht
ach wie froh und munter sollte die
stimmung zu beginn einer weihnachtswoche
sein und wie getrübt ist sie auch in
diesem jahr und damit guten abend liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer willkommen
zu diesem zdf spezial ja eine schöne
bescherung ist dass statt fröhlicher
feiern im familienkreis treibt
deutschland die sorge um vor einer
rasanten ausbreitung der omicron
variante schon jetzt verdoppelt sich
ihre infizierten zahl binnen weniger
tage ein szenario das wenn es nicht
ausgebremst wird bis zu 700.000 tägliche
neuinfektionen zur folge haben könnte
selbst dort wo man bisher einigermaßen
glimpflich durch die vierte welle
gekommen ist wird auch durch die
grenznähe zu dänemark plötzlich alles
anders henner hebestreit
unbeeindruckt von pandemischen sorgen
fliegt weihnachtswichtel kilian noch bis
23 dezember dreimal täglich über den
kieler weihnachtsmarkt und auch weiter
im norden in flensburg trotzen sie der
angst vor omikron auch wenn viel weniger
besucher als sonst kommen vor allem die
für flensburgs einzelhandel so wichtigen
gäste aus dem benachbarten dänemark
bleiben aus
ja nicht der rede wert hier
es ist sehr so viel schlechter als sonst
und wir merken dass auch die dänen sind
auch weniger hier als sonst auf der
anderen seite der grenze haben die dänen
am samstag ein letztes mal den tivoli
von euros besucht seitdem ruht das
öffentliche neben dänemarks weitgehend
mit sich omikron nicht weiter so rasant
ausbreitet die frage ob man deswegen
auch in deutschland allgemeine kontakt
beschränkungen verhängen sollte spaltet
die menschen im norden
manchen sind unbelehrbar
wir machen den ganzen wirtschaft kaputt
ich für die ungeimpften würde ich es
sehr gut finden aber für die geimpften
bin ich ein bisschen gespalten also
locker und für alle finde ich nicht gut
lock down für ungeimpfte einfach weil
das vielleicht ein bisschen mehr druck
auf die leute vernünftig zu sein und er
sollte schon relativ weit kommen ich
denke nach weihnacht
in den geschäften allerdings hält man
nichts von lok darum überlegungen man
sieht sich gut aufgestellt
der einzelhandel hat in dieser pandemie
ist sehr gute erfahrungen mit seinen
hygiene konzept gemacht selbst das lka
hat in seinem chor it control papier
gesagt dass das infektionsrisiko im
einzelhandel als gering einzustufen ist
das liegt an alle masken pflicht den
kurzen kontakten und jetzt auch noch
zweig insofern ist die sorge vor der
virusvariante nicht so groß wie die
sorge vor einem weiteren bagdad
das einloggen den kieler
weihnachtswichtel und den einzelhandel
vor dem fest noch ausbremst gilt aber
als eher unwahrscheinlich
und in düsseldorf begrüße ich den
ministerpräsidenten von nordrhein
westfalen und vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
hendrik wüst guten abend herr wüst show
guten abend was hat denn für sie höchste
priorität was müssen bund und länder
morgen unbedingt beschließen so die
allerhöchste priorität hat der
gesundheitsschutz der schutz der
menschen und
mit blick auf omikron ist nach wie vor
oder sagen wir lieber mehr denn je
wachsamkeit und konzentriertes handeln
gefordert und wir sind immer dann
besonders erfolgreich und auch
konsistent in unserem agieren wenn die
staatlichen ebenen gemeinsam unterwegs
sind ihr parteikollege daten die günther
ministerpräsident von schleswig holstein
sieht allerdings so sagt es zumindest
keinen bedarf für weitere beschlüsse
morgen wie viel einigkeit ist angesichts
dessen zu erwarten
ich glaube mit blick auf omikron sollten
wir den fahrplan für die nächsten wochen
abstimmen eine strategie jedenfalls mal
über den jahreswechsel stehen themen auf
der agenda die wichtig sind das thema
aufrechterhaltung von kritischer
infrastruktur ist eines wie halten wir
unser land am laufen denn viele menschen
infiziert sind oder in quarantäne das
thema booster kampagne wie setzen wir
den erfolg der letzten wochen fort auch
im neuen jahr wir schaffen hier in
nordrhein westfalen zwischen anderthalb
millionen und 2 millionen impfungen pro
wochen ist ein riesenerfolg das muss
aber auch so weitergehen und der
expertenrat der bundesregierung hat in
einem einmütigen votum darum gebeten
dass wir dafür sorgen dass kontakte
reduziert werden aus auch das steht
morgen auf der agenda auch das müssen
wir angehen kontakt beschränkungen für
geimpfte und genesende wahrscheinlich ab
dem 28 dezember aber wäre das nicht ein
ungeheurer dämpfer für menschen die sich
haben impfen lassen die alles gemacht
haben was die politik gesagt hat und nun
teilweise so behandelt werden würden die
ungeimpfte ja das treibt mich auch um
politik hat im sommer den menschen
gesagt lass dich impfen dann bist du aus
dem schneider dieses virus lehrt uns
wieder einmal etwas neues mit der
omicron variante reichen eben zwei
impfungen sicher nicht mehr auch die
dritte impfung ist nötig die
auffrischungsimpfung und kann nur noch
die verläufe mildern nicht mal mehr den
hundertprozentigen schutz bieten das ist
natürlich eine eine schwere bürde jetzt
in den nächsten wochen aber auch ein
stück hoffnung denn die dritte impfung
immerhin schützt halt und deswegen
müssen wir die menschen bitten die
booster chance zu nutzen das tun sie bei
uns in nordrhein westfalen sehr sehr
vorbildlich das läuft wunderbar aber es
muss eben auch von immer mehr menschen
gemacht werden von noch mehr menschen
gemacht werden und ja die zwei impfungen
alleine reichen eben nicht aus um
sicherheit zu schaffen deshalb die
herzliche bitte der experten an uns und
ich denke wir werden das morgen auch
umsetzen kontakte deutlich zu reduzieren
wir sind sehr gespannt auf die
ergebnisse der morgigen bund länder
runde die ab 16 uhr in einer video
konferenz tagt und auch darüber werden
wir natürlich berichten herr
ministerpräsident
danke für das gespräch und großer
düsseldorf dann gehen wie das
der omicron ist eigentlich nur ein
harmloser buchstabe aus dem griechischen
alphabet aber er steht für eine ganz und
gar nicht harmlose virusvariante eine
die ihr unwesen weit infektiöser treibt
als delta und leichter unter den mantel
des menschen schlüpft selbst eine dritte
impfung soll nur bedingt vor einer
ansteckung mit omikron schützen welche
schlüsse aus wissenschaftlicher sicht
daraus zu ziehen sind darüber sprechen
wir gleich zunächst aber maike kneifel
mit zahlen und fakten
omikron laut whu nachgewiesen in 89
ländern weltweit
deutschland inzwischen umgeben von
hochrisiko gebieten großbritannien seit
heute sogar virusvarianten gebiet in den
nachbarländern ist zu beobachten was
auch auf uns zukommen könnte nach
aussagen der wissenschaftler zu kommen
wird in einigen europäischen regionen
verdoppeln sich die zahlen der omicron
infektionen alle zwei bis drei tage eine
exponentielle entwicklung für
deutschland melden das rkw und andere
institute bisher 240 bestätigte omikron
fälle mit blick auf die nachbarländer
gehen epidemiologen jedoch davon aus
dass die neue virus variante auch hier
bereits einen anteil von 10 bis 20
prozent der neuinfektionen ausmacht
was fehlt sind aktuelle belastbare daten
ein grund im vergleich zu beispielsweise
dänemark und großbritannien werden hier
deutlich weniger positive corona tests
genetisch untersucht gerade mal fünf bis
zehn prozent ausgesucht per
zufallsprinzip nur wenn bereits der
verdacht auf eine neue variante vorliegt
muss sequenziert also genetisch
überprüft werden wie viele omikron fälle
gibt es tatsächlich und wie ansteckend
ist diese virusvariante in
modellierungen versuchen nun
wissenschaftler mögliche szenarien das
infektionsgeschehen für deutschland zu
zeigen die ansteckende omikron im
vergleich zu delta eingestuft wird desto
steiler steig der omicron kurve das
worst-case-szenario mitte februar gebe
es 700.000 omikron infektionen täglich
jetzt haben wir mitte dezember und
stehen vor gänzlich neuen
herausforderungen über die ich mit
professor dirk brockmann sprechen möchte
physiker und wurde lehrer an der
berliner humboldt universität und am
robert koch institut für guten abend
nach berlin
guten abend was die übertragbarkeit
angeht stellt nikon ja alle bisherigen
varianten in den schatten wie kriegen
wir die doch noch unter kontrolle
wir müssen sozusagen alle maßnahmen
greifen die wirksam sind das ist in
erster linie
ostern so dass die immunität wieder
angehoben werden wird in der bevölkerung
weil ja omikron sich in der doppelt
geimpften bevölkerung einfach frei
ausbreiten kann und natürlich kontakt
beschränken also alles machen was unsere
effektiven kontakte beschränkt was würde
es denn tatsächlich nach ihren
modellrechnungen bedeuten wohin würde es
führen wenn es jetzt keine weitergehende
zum beispiel kontakt beschränkungen gebe
also es gibt verschiedene
modellrechnungen insbesondere für
großbritannien die sich zwar nicht
direkt übertragen lassen aber in
größenordnung auf jeden fall genutzt
werden können um so genannte worst case
szenarien zu berechnen und laut dieser
modelle und prognosen ist es durchaus
realistisch dass man mit dreistelligen
also hunderttausenden von infektionen
pro tag rechnen kann und das würde halt
das gesamte system
total belasten und um genau das zu
verhindern gehen ja einige unserer
nachbarn doch weiter zum beispiel in den
niederlanden wo inzwischen ein strenger
lockdown geht und zwar auch für geimpfte
und gelesene ist das richtig dass die
politik so was für deutschland jetzt
schon ausschließt
also wenn wir auf diese prognosen gucken
und schauen dann ist ja das was
vermieden werden soll durch solche
maßnahmen das nämlich zur gleichen zeit
ganz viele menschen sich infizieren und
selbst wenn man mal die aus vitali
sierung außen vor lässt einfach nur die
tatsache dass wenn sich mehrere
hunderttausend menschen pro tag invest
infizieren sehr sehr viele menschen
gleichzeitig krank werden würden und
damit sozusagen auch die kritische
infrastruktur
kompromittieren würden und das soll
damit vermieden werden dann werden ja
bund und länder höchst wahrscheinlich
morgen kontakt beschränkungen eben auch
für geimpfte und genesene beschließen
ohne die bereitschaft eines jeden
einzelnen wird es aber nicht gehen wie
lässt sich denn nach fast zwei jahren
corona und das frage ich ja auch als
sozialwissenschaftler die bevölkerung
noch motivieren mitzumachen
also die man dass die maßnahmen für
geimpfte und genesene gelten ist
natürlich total richtig weil omikron ja
auch sich in der doppel kämpften
bevölkerung eigentlich freie ausbreiten
kann diese impfung schützt zwar deutlich
vor schwerer erkrankung aber nicht
bremst nicht die infektions dynamik
deshalb ist das schon mal richtig was
die motivation angeht so müssen wir halt
schauen wie das in der ersten welle war
dass wir dass es eindeutig und klar
kommuniziert wird was hier passieren
kann dass die bevölkerung das auch
versteht also dass wir dann auch wie in
der ersten welle sozusagen kollektiv und
als gemeinschaft
dann diese fünfte welle möglichst
verzögern verringern können sodass nicht
zu jedem zeitpunkt das system also es
wird auch auf eine
kommunikationsstrategie ankommen die das
ganze mit begleitet professor borgmann
danke für ihre einschätzungen und größe
nach berlin
hätte für
ja und beide gespräche in diesem spezial
haben wir kurz vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet
omikron das ist die unschöne bescherung
zum festen verleidet uns das fest so
viel steht fest aber ob die variante
noch größeren schaden anrichten kann das
hängt davon ab ob bund und länder morgen
an einem strang ziehen und letztlich wir
alle mitziehen wenn es darum geht diese
pandemie endlich endlich hinter uns zu
lassen das war unser zdf spezial hier im
programm folgt die wiso dokumentation
über kinder allein im netz wie sicher
sind tik tok und co und ihnen noch einen
schönen abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]